l'histoire que je vais vous lire est une
histoire écrite en bilingue en français
et en créole moi aujourd'hui je vais
vous la lire en créole l'auteur
et m'a donné et l'illustrateur au Haro
c'est l'histoire d'un petit poussin qui
veut grandir trop vite
il faisait juste 21 jours que mon
ampoule avait pris le nid
tout d'un coup elle a entendu
Piou Piou sous sa zèle
intigiguine Piou Piou dans les 12 oeufs
qu'elle avait couvé un seul laver éclos
quand la coquille a cassé
un petit Guigui poulet la sortie
les joues passées
petits poulets grandissent pas
même la plume laver toutes les peines du
monde voir où sont encore
tous les sous
debouts
qui chantait à faire qu'à son gosier
tellement jolie avec son banc de plume
la soie
mais ça petit poulet yeux qu'envie
c'était sa queue
sa belle que qui brillait dans le soleil
grand matin
moment
savez-vous voudrait plus que toutes cm
que pareil ça le coq
pour un patience mon petit gâté un jour
au tour va arriver
sûrement petit poulet n'avait pas envie
d'attendre
la partie roi de berkana
sauvée elle avait un bon conseil pour
donner à lui
S
les deux vertèbres d'un coup sans
respirer
demain demain ma vie ça va prendre un
autre tournure
dans
titanicie et son petit scorpion tout nu
tu voulais la planche la tête lui la
partie
mais
ça le coq à cause la mienne il pousse
pas
demain demain rien sera plus pareil
aujourd'hui
lendemain matin
quand il a décidé
pour moi
5000 voudrait cm que pareil ça le coq à
cause la mienne n'y pousse pas
plus jolie carotte ananas
avant de faire son yeux pour la nuit
carotte là jusqu'au Gondon
demain demain sera un gay un jour pour
moi
dans le
matiniki et son petit scorpion tout nu
l'armée roulait dans son yeux il
appartient
tout le monde y disait que T elle-même
la plus futée dans les parages
ça le coq à cause d'un mien il pousse
pas
tis
poulet il tremblait quand il a Antoine
son case avant de rentrer dans son
hippodrome du lac a fait cactus
doucement doucement tension et
pinypicali
demain moi sera aussi jolie que lui
demain moi sera en l'air
lendemain grand matin
l'heure qu'il a levé les langues
qui et son petit scorpion tout nu
pour le coup il a quitte la ferme dans
sa tête n'avait été engage et il a
marché marché loin sur le chemin à force
il arrive au bord d'un rivière
là dans la boue à moitié cachée
un bel crocodile dépôt veille à lui
bonjour monsieur le crocodile
à palais ça lui finir la roue van girl
grand comme un cavernes et lui il a dit
avec ou sans que pour moi vivait même
pas une bouchée
de mâchoires avec un désordre terrible
c'est dans pointu la rase la tête
tiboulée à deux trois centimètres pas
plus
inutile d'irazote tiboulet lapin moisi
est là il a couru couru jamais ces deux
types l'avaient trouvé tes vêtements
comme ça
un moment donné lutter les gain il pue
son ticket il bat dans son dos tu es
paré vous casse par boutique
la longes à terre pour apprendre un
petit peu faveur
et là il a réfléchi
un tas de citer la passe dans son
machination
à partir du sortira plus de la ferme
autant que possible lui va jouer avec
son bandalon et lui va arrête en garde à
lui tous les matins toutes côtés
le temps la passe comme ça même jusqu'à
un jour ou circulation